لذا خذ هذا الشخص الذي تعرفه
يتحول إلى فيسبوك متطرف
الآن يسأل هذا السؤال
الدقيق للأشخاص الذين يستخدمون النظام الأساسي ، تحقق من
ذلك بعض مستخدمي المواقع الاجتماعية
هنا في الولايات المتحدة الذين
يتلقون الآن موجهًا يسأل عما إذا
كانوا قلقين من أن شخصًا ما
ربما تعلم أنك قد تعرف ، عفواً ،
ربما أصبح
متطرفًا ويتم إخطار الآخرين
بأنهم ربما تعرضوا
لمحتوى متطرف ، حسنًا ،
إنها نسخة على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي من تلك
التحذيرات الصحية على علبة سجائر
الآن ، أصبح فيسبوك يخضع
لتدقيق شديد  حقًا
من النقاد لعدم اتخاذ
إجراءات كافية لتقليص المحتوى المتطرف
على منصتها ،
حث مجلس الرقابة المستقل
للشركة الشركة
على التحقيق في الدور الذي لعبته منصتها
في تمرد السادس من يناير ،
لكن التطرف ليس المشكلة الوحيدة
لـ facebook في الوقت الحالي ، فهناك
الكثير من المعلومات الخاطئة هناك أيضًا
ويقول رئيس موظفي البيت الأبيض
إنه تحدث إلى faceboo
مارك زوكربيرج رئيس k حول هذا الموضوع ، أخبر رون كلاين
نيويورك تايمز أنه أثار
مسألة لقاح الطمع على
المنصة وأعتقد أن فيسبوك نفسه قد بنى
عددًا من
الأدوات لمساعدة الناس في العثور على اللقاحات وما إلى
ذلك ،
لكنني فعلت ذلك  أخبر مارك زوكربيرج مباشرة
أنه
عندما نجمع مجموعات من الأشخاص الذين
لم يتم تطعيمهم
ونسألهم أه لماذا لم يتم
تطعيمهم ويخبروننا بأشياء خاطئة
أخبرنا بأشياء غير صحيحة
ونسألهم أين سمعوا ذلك
الجواب الأكثر شيوعًا هو facebook ،
لذلك وعد facebook بعمل أفضل في
وقف تدفق المعلومات المضللة
ونظريات المؤامرة
، وعليهم الآن المتابعة.